there's my girl noticed you handing out
some shekels how would one get on that
train that was per diem for Philadelphia
oh I was like cheesesteaks that town is
full of history Andrea's the office
[ __ ] you'll get used to her hmm
creep I'm not offended by homosexuality
in the 60s I made love to many many
women often outdoors in the mud in the
rain and as possible a man slipped in he
would be no way of knowing so strike
scream and run all right let's try it
Stanley that I have asthma cuz I don't
if it gets out they won't let me scuba
if I can't scuba then what's this all
been about what am i working toward
Creed yes sir
everything okay everything is cool dude
I'm thirty well in November I'll be
thirty that is Northern Lights cannabis
indica no it's marijuana I may have
inside information than someone is
hiding drugs in its very office just
pretend like we're talking until the
cops leave
thank playing a little hooky from work
today oh my god
how much they want $300 what no I could
get a fish for a five cent worm
oh you're paying way too much for worms
man who's your worm guy so hey I want to
set you up with my daughter along
engaged to Pam I thought you were gay
why would you want to set me up with a
daughter I don't know hey cuz heard
you're having money problems no you
didn't listen I got the answer you
declare bankruptcy
Oh your problems go away Creed Bratton
has never declared bankruptcy when Creed
Bratton gets in trouble he transfers his
debt to William Charles Schneider Creed
I noticed you don't have a resolution on
the board what's yours I want to do a
cartwheel they're real casual like no no
make a big deal out of it but I know
everybody saw it there's one stunning
gorgeous cartwheel how's it going I'm
having a little trouble motivating no if
you do that I'm gonna do that if you do
that I'm gonna do that if you do this
I'm gonna do that oh yeah you don't want
to do that I'm just hiding out until all
this stuff blows over with Creed playing
chess at work he's winning
I feel him ascribing a dream I had yo
new chair know he hasn't picked one yet
dad
when Pam gets Michael's wheelchair I get
Pam's old chair then I'll have two
chairs only one to go
I've been involved in a number of cults
both as a leader and a follower get more
fun as a follower but you make more
money as a leader
whoa awesome let's put a smile on that
face
damnit Crees I've been up since 4:00
it's real shame about it huh yeah must
really have you thinking about what the
older you get the bigger the chances
you're gonna die you know that ed was
decapitated
he was drunk as a skunk he was flying
down Route six he slides under an
18-wheeler pop it snaps right off that
is the way to go
instant death a very smart you know a
human can go on living for several hours
after being decapitated you're thinking
I'm a chicken what did I say someone
complained that the men's room is whites
only San Li you know that's not true
I didn't say that and why is there a
picture of a white man on the door I
already won the lottery I was born in
the US of A baby
and it's back up I have a Swiss Passport
does it hurt terribly no it's not too
bad they had me on a lot of painkillers
oh really
what kind Cody vicodin percocet fentanyl
oxycontin Haleh don't no idea
the man I run a small fake ID company
from my car with a laminating machine
that I swiped from the show station I
understand that's confusing hey brah
I've been meaning to ask you can we get
some Red Bull for these things sometimes
a guy's got to ride the bull
am i right later skater look at where
you're going to be doing the cartwheel
so look where you're going to be placing
your hand so pick a spot mm-hmm you
ready to do this you sir
you know what I'm gonna stay here as
long as it takes I really appreciate I
miss my spot you go I did you did the
perfect cartwheel huh okay good
the rush that's all I had to do all your
congratulations
alright well alright see you tomorrow oh
my god
I find it offensive on naturale baby
that's how I like him swing low Sweet
Chariot s' look at that she's totally
flirting with him you don't know that
some people can't help losing sexuality
you ever noticed you're gonna only lose
two things sexuality and Plus man I tell
ya it's a beautiful morning at
dunder-mifflin as I like to call it
great Bratton keep it running do I love
being manager I love my kids I love real
estate I love ceramics I love my job I
love wrestling find out what language
this is my family care Fafnir lost our
femur geez doorbot nobody's just from
creed bratton gets away with it the last
person to do this disappeared his name
great breath I didn't realize that
everybody here dresses up every year me
neither
it's Halloween that is really really
good timing you told Toby that Creed has
a distinct old man smell I know exactly
what he's talking about I sprouted mung
beans on a damp paper towel in my desk
drawer very nutritious but they smelling
death can you tell us what happened
um I was walking to the building and
this man asked me for directions and he
was holding a map and when I walked over
he had it out on the map Phyllis you're
a married woman the guy was just hanging
brain I mean what's all the fuss if
that's flashing then lock me up the
Taliban is the worst great heroin though
Oh
cool beans man I live by the quarry we
should hang out by the quarry and throw
things down there
okay team-building on this side of the
room Stanley Phyllis Jim
Ted Elroy and this side of the room Pam
Meredith Phyllis Creed you never called
a meeting
everybody this is Creed and he is in
charge of something that right correct
say hi to the kids hi kids
yeah you ever seen a foot with four toes
[Music]
no no would you cut it out
bow body bow body what is the first B
stand for what are we doing we're making
acronyms okay what is the first B stand
for um business I like it business good
Kevin all right do we need a new manager
what are you doing in here this is the
woman's room you're in here I pay for
that privilege
you